I'm always glad to see you why don't you
come help me out hey there so we got to
play set of decay true for around two
hours and what you're watching now is a
couple of missions that I captured
during the course of these we will place
summer in the mid-game with a built up
base and a crew of survivors so in the
next 20 minutes we'll see a couple of my
adventures with Agnes and I'll be
chiming in every now and again to give
you some context about what's happening
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Hey
so here I answered a survivor distress
call and this guy wants me to help him
find some medicine we're hoping that by
helping him we'll gain a few points
progression as well as find some good
resources along the way
sure thing okay you're Lee
you'll notice that there's the ability
to fall search now which is way way
faster than regular searching that runs
the risk of attracting a bunch of
zombies in the nearby area and it's not
just one or two it's a whole bunch of
them so that's not good
never luck next time
I think I'll take that
yes see you around
I'm exhausted I need to rest
[Music]
kind of freaking my sites here I'm
really happy I rolled the character with
a grenade launcher by the way
[Music]
now the Shriekers are back and obviously
they'll stun you if you don't knock them
out first which I didn't do in this
instance
watch where you're shooting
so there's a feed pausing issues obvious
here and I feel like that's kind of a
stay of decayed junk thing although they
did ask us to specify that this was a
pre-release built
that's not going to fit
now here is me being very disappointed
that I couldn't drive this semi trail
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please let this be the right place get
some seeds roaster than I like
I've got no time for this you can
probably tell I've been playing a lot of
pub G lately sorry
can't carry that
exactly what I was looking for now I've
been a little bit lacks on my inventory
management here since I knew I wasn't in
this for the long run so bear with me
[Music]
look what I found
[Music]
huge [ __ ] thanks I can't I both love
and hate the fact that this guy decided
he was done and wanted to go the rest of
his way on foot even though I have a
sweet Jeep and a populated base to go
back to
[Music]
[Applause]
now coming up as a moment right out of
any good zombie film you've made the
trek back with all your supplies you're
finally home and at the very last second
you get swarmed by enemies at the
entrance and come super super close to
death
getting beat up here
[Music]
it's a good thing this base was already
populated with help is but these are the
kind of tense moments that makes Dave
decay so good hello there stay safe okay
so this is a characteristic mission and
once you switch to that character you
have to do it or it's basically lost
forever at least that's what it seemed
like while we were playing it this one
has us hunt out and destroy a plague
hunt which generates the new plague
zombies which can infect your character
and turn them into zombies it's new
buddy don't be gone for too long you can
find these during the regular game and
destroy them as any character but they
usually guarded by a ton of zombies
[Music]
I'm pretty proud of this road Mangala I
upgraded the yellow muscle car you might
have seen parked at the very beginning
of this video and now it's way more
durable and Mad Max like I feel like
getting a really good vehicle situation
happening instead of just relying on
whatever is around is pretty key to
state decay but maybe that's just how I
like to play
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so you see that meteor in the bottom
left there the more you come into
contact with plague zombies your risk of
contracting the plague will rise I just
have to get this done
okay so that was a relatively unguarded
plague hot and the others I saw through
my playthrough but maybe that's just
because it was part of this character
mission
[Music]
this place seems safe for now
[Music]
Laurie can't carry that I'm a little
full at the moment
[Music]
I should be more careful
[Music]
I really enjoy knowing that you have to
maintain and refuel you'll be able to
save decay - you have to keep stopping
you're trying to do that I just love
that feeling of always having to be on
top of a bunch of things in games like
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this would be a great place for an
outpost I imagined
[Music]
better luck next time
[Music]
we're looking to trade if you're
interested now that I've claimed this
gun shop as an outpost it increases the
mo stockpiles I have by small amount
each day back at home base
I don't think we're going to find
anything else here
some goodies with the neighbors
air is making my eyes burn must be a
plague heart nearby alright cool so he's
a regular plague hot and I think this
one is a little more exciting than the
last one
just spotted a play cards
now be sure to watch out for the
super-casual toss the grenade over my
shoulder moon doing that made me feel
super cool which I am not usually
[Music]
so you see what I mean about how
difficult these things usually are to
take out so rushing in and trying to
finish off that play cut was probably a
bad idea and at this point I have
actually contracted the Blood Plague
which means Agnes is going to die
eventually and unless I had the means
for treatment so that was probably a
very risky move to do especially without
a pot mckerrod Oh
[Music]
you need to check yourself in there are
a few ways of dealing with the Blood
Plague you can construct an infirmary
back at your home base and then upgrade
it so they can treat it then you assign
the survivor there and they'll get
better eventually but this does take a
long time and the materials you need to
actually craft the blood plague to a
come from hearts themselves but there
are other options you can take so you
can exhale the survivor from your camp
or even shoot them in the head right
then and there which is pretty grim but
hey that's state of decay and with Agnes
infant treatment I'm gonna close it up
there thanks for watching through this
entire state of decay to do the games
coming out for real on may 22 on PC and
exponent a state decays stuff up on
gamespot.com so be sure to check that
stuff out as well this place is like a
[ __ ] beacon for zombies